[Music]
hello and welcome to another chess on
psychology on wednesday i hope you guys
enjoyed danish
um i like his classes it's a new edition
it's kind of fun
today finally after like six weeks we
are trying to
show you some of nega's book and my
personal experiences with it well
technically two weeks ago on twitch we
did a little bit of it
but today we're gonna be talking a bit
about philidor hopefully wrapping it up
next week uh diving more into french
probably another week after that another
week after that so it's gonna be a while
all right i hope everybody's having a
great week
i am pretty jet-lagged so we'll see how
this goes
okay
i don't really see any questions in chat
so i am ready to jump right in
let's jump right in
okay so
uh some of the things i'm going to show
you is in this villa door is
just
primarily my experience so it's um i got
the inspirations from nega's book after
reading it
but i didn't necessarily um
go every did everything he said because
well i wanted to
kind of add a little bit of my own to it
too but let's just dive in
so
usually in philadelphia people don't
take but that's a whole different story
that we're not going to talk about right
now
but
in this case let's say they do take
you take back with the knight and now
black has a few options and one of these
games that
i have here
i'm very um well happy about because it
was
the first
game
after i got my first i am norm
and i was playing the same opponent that
i beat the last
tournament so it was kind of funny and
this this time i beat team two it was
the first round so i had a very good
start and i got my second arm too
but
it was an enorm game technically because
it wasn't the last round but it
definitely helped
so
let's start with knight f6 knight f6 is
the um
most common one g6 is a little bit uh
for me it's a little bit well it makes
me definitely happier because i know
you're going to do bishop g7 and i know
i want to try and set up for long castle
you're going to set up short castle so
it already gives me a bit of an
edge
uh one of the things i tell my students
whenever
they are trying to like figure out how
to play in an unknown opening is i just
tell them okay so picture
where do you want to put your pieces if
you know for sure where this bishop
belongs go for it usually they don't
for bishops usually they're like okay so
i really know like for example here
knight c3 makes sense because i know
this knight wants to be on c3 so first
do that then decide about which bishop
to get up next which side you want
castle but you know for sure this knight
lungs on c3 so go do that
now
i'm going to do that to you
first of all which bishop do you think
you should get out which side do you
want to castle and well if you decide to
get either of the bishops out now where
do you want to go with them
i have
two potential
answers from the audience okay maybe
three
and hopefully
my
chats will also
say something
because i can see anything yet
it's probably not a
[ __ ] at the moment
i can look it up from phone if that's
more convenient
if you want to if you can otherwise i'll
pull it up and get it on the screen oh
i like bishop v3 yeah bishop v3 so
you're probably setting up shop for lawn
caster right yeah perfect [ __ ]
everything very logical very comfortable
and now
now what are you going to try and get
bishop c4 first are you going to leave
this bishop b and still continue for
your long castle idea
that's not the unreasonable fear but
let's say
so
what wha well
are you thinking
that's fair but surely you're gonna like
in two
one or two moves you're gonna play f3 to
support g4 so bishop e2 might not be
needed
and even if you wanted to get like
bishop g5
um
if knight g4 happens that's also
possible
so
i'm assuming you're weighing between
queen d2 or bishop e2
oh no i was also thinking about three or
four oh um honestly
after i think it's all right here
because
you still want to do the cleanup castle
so i'm not
i mean it's fine in my eyes so if you're
concerned about f2 should be okay too uh
queen is also okay if you go knight g4 i
always have this bishop g5 and if you
play f6
good luck castling and i'll just move it
away and bishop c4 will be a monster so
i'm happy with this but if i didn't have
bishop g5 yeah you're right
um
so
let's say castle now are you going to
castle or are you going to get bishop
answer
i mean okay so the main difference
between this and uh
like my dark lines is because
obviously the
e pawn isn't there so that's why you can
do the pg
gotta try to
i'm sorry
deaf the audience sorry guys
um let me also pull up
from here so i can see the chat okay now
it's the chat
hmm
yeah let's go for it ah such a long ad
and all i want to do is see
there we go
nice i like this long castle now let's
say
normal moves let's say opponent just
develops what do you do
oh that's tracy sorry for
um
look every few weeks i do a sneeze and
it's so close to the microphone i test
everybody's hearing so
at this point it's a given
so what do we do
i like that but why not that f3 idea so
that one of the big things is
in my experience when you were already
done this long castle i don't want to
get this bishop out too soon because i
don't want opponent to get handsy with
my bishop and i don't want to let them
like
um develop and get their pawns out and
then i have to move my bishop they
attack it so i just don't want to make
my opponent happy so
hashtag dorsal philosophy
yeah so i don't really bishop c4 is a
good diagonal don't get me wrong but it
also kind of gives opponents some ideas
so
i'll let it be
and just for the fun of it let's say
they take we take and they try to get a
little bit
developing and potentially they're not
even attacking just
developing at this point and let's say
we just get going keep going
now what do you think about this
position
ah technically you could see answers up
there it's kind of fun
here
[Laughter]
it's either plus or minus two
[Laughter]
well your knight is bent
to your queen but could you push
so as a general principle i don't want
to touch any of my kings like the king
defender
so because it's especially in opposite
side castles the more you touch these
pawns the more opponent can come and
attack them that's that's kind of the
similar principle that i don't want to
make my opponent happy by giving them a
tempo to attack my pieces so as a
general principle i'm not going to touch
these pawns unless i absolutely have to
so even if they're attacking this
i still prefer not to touch that so for
example let's say we continue with our
attack
so yes the chat is talking about this is
kind of a dragon style structure you're
not wrong yeah
oh also i like that brian clark dorset
the hopes and dreams slayer can we get
the official title somewhere
but oh i do have one other piece of good
news i have my second acceptance to a
different medical school so one is in
kentucky one is in kansas state
i have to choose between them and their
deposits are so expensive
and i have former waitlist
but
it'll be a fun next few months you'll
definitely hear me venting about it on
stream so
all right um
now
how did i go from hopes and dreams
slayers to that but yes
how do you feel about bishop h6
so tracy i'm not going to give specifics
just because i feel weird naming
universities i'm just going to talk
states
for now
hello vivek
ah someone's asking was king b1 also an
alternate it was but bishop h6 is the
best one so my thing is i want you to
calculate bishop a2 and let me know if
it's good for black or
you know well why did we choose bishop
h6 and not just because the computer
tells us
is this a nice attack are you liking
this attack
yeah this bishop is quite strong right
so it's one of the the pieces that
opponent is using to bring more pressure
to our king so it does make a lot of
sense to want to eliminate it but is
that the only thing is that the only
reason you're playing this special h6
if they take well great this is giving
us a direct attack to on h file but
there also have some ideas to take on um
a2 so again you have to be very careful
with how you are going to do this so
let's say they take
now what you're gonna do
there's one specific line that
does
give you pretty cool advantage
ah b3 queen a3 checkmate
i love it
i've done stuff like that
to my opponents but like i took with the
bishop they played b3 and i brought the
other bishop on i gave checkmates
i love those
yeah you went there to get rid of this
bishop do it now what
this other bishop is kind of
in my eye so
and now there's a new pin this diagonal
is now yours so
i'm gonna do a huge jump back in time
you also want to do g5 by the way soon
but
see
one of the biggest
things that
always scares me when i try to fiance to
my bishop when i've already touched my
e-pawn is
this diagonal looks very fancy very good
but it also gives you permanent
weaknesses now if there was another pawn
on e7 like in
in like king's indians
then it's a little bit different because
this bishop yes it's better or like in
dragon for example it's
less um your king is less exposed the
square this f6 square is less uh
vulnerable
and you know worst case now you can just
throw in an e5 and just close up the
diagonal so you have more stuff to
help your diagonal and help your king
and your safety and all those so
that's kind of
one of the reasons i'm very skeptical
for
for me playing this
pawn structures but
again your opponent also should know how
to do it now we talked a little about
this knight c6 and like the
hypotheticals of what would happen if
they want to eat but they don't have to
eat you know they could just develop and
now we would continue with our attack
and this is still very advantageous for
white because white has an attack black
doesn't black if this pawn was like on
b4 yeah okay now we can now we can talk
about um
the problems but now let's go back a
little bit i'm very ready to wrap up
this g6 line let's talk about rook e8
let's talk let's say they played a
different angle at angle instead of
doing stuff like this let's say they
start attacking pawns
what would you do then also tracy where
are you going i'm jet lagged why are you
leaving
dorsey when was this game played
2000
not 15 16.
yes uh
i know it was in serbia
okay
i played a few tournaments there
and i also want to do the
february question mark
oh man i played way too many tournaments
back in the day i remember specifically
i had like a tournament plan that i did
i went to belgium for a round robin it
was fine i got a few points but i didn't
really get the norm then i went to this
uh tournaments it was like two of them
and then i from here i flew directly to
like there was back to back not even a
day and then i went to austria for a
league
and i closed 2400 there and then from
austria i flew to
moscow for airfloat and i think i burned
out after that because it was
it was like five tournaments in a row
and then i took a break and i did it
again
but yeah so
i don't recommend that by the way
prepare play like 10 games sit down
analyze them
50 games
all right
so what everything here
are we still liking this f3 idea
all right let's go f3 we're setting up
shop for g4 h4 ideas also this this is
not the game yet
the game was not g6 just to confirm this
is still like analysis on what would
happen if they did this g6
okay
now
let's say they continue with the idea we
can again do our plan so
this setup for f3 g4 is very
um something that i really really like
when i'm playing opposite side castles
so i've had experiences with this like
specific pawn structure uh in
scotch for example you know in scotch
when they play bishop c5 knight b3
bishop b6 you can set up for this ideas
in a lot of sicilians you can have these
ideas especially dragon
um
i know french unfortunately
but hey if if your opponent ends up
getting a structure like this and you
end up in opposite side castles
which can happen a lot from pier modern
some weird curl comes you can still you
know still do this specific pawn attack
for the structure so
hello eduardo
all right
now let's say for example again this is
something that also does happen in
scotch too
this idea is with d5 or just ideas with
knight e5
i mean it's a little different because
you don't usually have this bishop on g7
when it comes to scratch
but
now let's say
d5 what do you do
yeah patrick you're correct yeah that is
the idea
if you do play this like ideas if upon
unless you play e4 d4 knight c3 without
c4 you can get into this structures yeah
yeah g5 thank you peter
g5 is pretty interesting because
opponent is attacking in the center and
this is one of the key defenders so
let's kick it bond is happy about it
let's take it away
now they gotta move this night now you
get to just get the pawn and even if
they exchange it i mean i'm pretty happy
i really enjoy this position
king b1
i guess possible two but
queen d2 makes more sense because even
if they exchange it
they can't really defend this problem so
you're gonna have a very pleasant
endgame
so yeah i'm happy about it
now let me do a mini jump back in time
let's say instead of d5 knight to e5 now
again in scotch i've also encountered
ideas with like 95 to be fair this
bishop is like here
but still 95 now what they're trying to
attack some of these
potential weaknesses
so
what do we do
also jack never play f3
i mean if your king is on g1 never play
f3 okay or if your king is still on e1
and this can get checked
maybe more and more yes then no but if
your king is in a whole different you
know part of the game go up by f3 who
cares
the whole idea is not to weaken your
king so
if it's not weakening your king do it
okay i'm getting a g5 i'm getting an h
for h5 yeah see that's kind of the
problem if you play h4 right now you
have to be careful about now you got to
move the horsey and bye-bye pawn and
your stretcher starts to
crumble a bit because then that'll also
fall and
we need pawns
so we're not just ready for a pawn storm
yet so this is a problem
however if we could correctly defend
them we could hope for something like f4
f5 as well
i love it yeah sometimes simple moves
are the best
now if they play c5 they're kind of
shooting themselves in the foot because
now this is a problem this square is
beautiful you can just hop up here and
pick this up and
who needs to attack when you can eat
ponds right
you could even play knight
it hurts me
i mean obviously
but it feels like you're so
good here that you could
if rook was on g1 or maybe your queen
was on g2
i would have considered it more
seriously but right now knight f5 it's a
little scary
actually never mind you can you might be
able to pull it off i'm still scared i
would just eat the pond first
then set it up for it but if you feel
like you want to go for blood sure why
not
i mean you get that skit
i wouldn't
no i wouldn't either in a tournament
game but i'm just curious if it's that
crazy no it's not that crazy it's just
i i love my i've became more
materialistic since i've had to start
paying for my medical schools
and
it's just
i like pawns
so yeah
that's another thing that i was
considering it could be possible the
only downside of it is your queen is
still you know serving a purpose here
yeah
so i'm not opposed to queen g2 because
i've done like queen g2 stuff
a lot in sicilian and in um
well sometimes on scotch but
i like it
but queen g2
[Music]
i think my biggest concern with it is
you still can't really do f4 because
this is falling and you still need like
two three more moves to set up any type
of attack here and you're not really
going to play g5 just yet so it
oh
well if they
oh sorry if they play c5 i mean
technically maybe
why not
look i would still prefer to eat this
pond first
um
i mean it's good but
not my not my thing right now
quinjuto is definitely doable
but since your queen is still serving a
purpose here there should be two also
but if you played queenie two i wouldn't
i'm trying to come up with the right
choice of word
i wouldn't
say bad stuff i would be proud of you
let's go with that yeah
all right
so now let's say we got this g5 and
finally f4 yeah or nay
oh we have musical chess tonight
soothing
hi manny it is a huge cup and i'm very
jet lagged so this is definitely going
to be helping
trying to see what else is in the chat
ah okay so i'm getting a no because of
knight g4
well
yes
but this if this knight comes on g4
we could also start thinking if we can
trap it
i'm getting a rook g1 suggestion
possible
but
[Music]
f4 does make sense because you can
simply just bring it back and you have a
serious threat with h3 you want to try
and you know pick stuff up so opponent
has to be very careful let's say
opponent tries to you know kick the
knight away
and they try to
i have no idea what they're trying to do
actually
tell me why not take with queen
why do you think we should take with
pawnee
yes
but even more than eating we don't want
opponent to eat
so what changes ah what changes if i
take with queen
what am i leaving behind
yeah so that's kind of the problem if we
take with the queen we're leaving behind
this guy and now this is a problem
actually pretty big problem so
yeah
again you are quite advantageous at this
moment
but you still need to be able to
convert that advantage to more material
and then more pieces and then win but
i'm gonna actually ask the audience to
make all the people to make guess how
much do you think white is better right
now what do you think engine is giving
it
no
oh look up there
it's an integer
you're looking up there
oh no not anymore
maybe you should bring a hat
cap next time
i used to do that actually when i'm not
into classes when i was playing
tournaments when i was like a
kid i want to say up until maybe 15. i
used to wear like a hat
well part of it was because i was trying
to avoid my country's regulations but
anyways but part of it was like it would
help me focus because i like i couldn't
really see anything around me and i
always thought that was kind of funny
but then when i stopped wearing the hat
i was like whoa there's so much more
light
but
yeah it was kind of fun or like still
when i played seriously then you know if
you check out any of the pictures or any
of the videos people still you know sit
and like focus like this so
i'm not sure how to if people still do
it when they're playing the
computer but
still
anyways
so how much do you think i'm getting a
lot of like
threes twos
i'm getting few fives
well actually yeah it is it's a little
over five but again not the most
accurate engine but still it's
white is winning
so
you have to be able to make that
determination that's you know if do the
moves you're doing how much approximate
advantage it gives you because if it if
you're like plus one here it's probably
not worth it but if you're plus five
then yeah you wanna know for sure what
you're doing because everything
is kind of wobbly so
so many things are happening you have to
be very very
precise with
how much advantage you have and how you
can use it you need to convert it to
something else this is the type that you
can you know attack it is it the
strategic advantage dynamic advantage
so it's a lot of things that you should
try and like run through in your head
decision making is really hard and just
and in life actually all right um i'm
kind of done with this g6
so this is just fun you can find better
lines too it doesn't have to be this one
you can eat here first for example so
many other options i'll also share the
link to this study because on leachates
at the end so you'll have access to this
as well
now i'm still done with this g6 let's go
back not look at g6 let's say 9x6 there
we go okay knight f6 kind of forces your
hand right you kind of got to go knight
c3 now
one final g6 question
what if g6 now
what would you do
what's different than the other g6
yep
even more torture
now after bishop g7
you can simply just get your queen out
the same way you wanted it
and you're still going to do the same
ideas let's say if the castle we castle
they get the work out we're just going
to do the chill things that we want to
do
the only difference is you you're not
obligated to push for f3 g4 immediately
and since your bishop is not here
i should probably mention that right
here since your bishop is not here if
they take you don't want to be forced to
take him with queen and end up in this
diagonal so you can just walk away
and
now this is such a scotch
knight style for me again usually this
bishop is here in scotch but and
whenever in scott's opponent plays a5 i
kind of have an immediate response to it
so what is your immediate response here
yeah kind of like like opponents really
is going to be happy if they get a4 and
kick my knight away so i'm just i'm just
gonna take that away from you
and even if opponent does this bishop b6
again this is such a scotch style
and they want to take it i don't care
you take i'm gonna take that i'm happy
pawn structure gets a little sucky but
that's okay
and i'm happy just
coming up with the attack on the king
side now
just for example this is not an exact um
game that i'm showing you but for
example this is how you could try to
manage your attack
and
one final thing what if they try and
kick your bishop out final thing about
g6 which then still not done with this
specific philidor ideas
why h4 because
i think
the king might castle on the king's side
so you might expose
that side
there is one slight thing with bishop h4
which i remember i've done it a few
times in
rousers
what if they take
because if you take back they'll pick
this guy up and if you take the queen
they'll pick up the queen and they're
still attacking
some of your materials sure
uh
i mean you can but
you don't really have advantage anymore
if anything opponent is the one who's
trying to push for more now
because opponents pieces just got really
active really quick
everything like uh your developed pieces
are quite wobbly you still have to
figure out when to castle and you still
have to
deal with opponents um opponent gets
momentum now
so opponent is the one who's going to be
doing the
thank you all right
so let's say bishop of four
and let's say they're just going to
continue developing now what they're
delaying their castle
oh hello from greece
we could we could consider moving this
or
i don't want to take this but i am open
to this bishop g5 bishop b5 ideas
because
if we go knight b3
there's no guarantee that they're gonna
go long castle so what i'm thinking is
what if they just kind of set up shop
for you know long castle two
just for for the fun of it
let's say i'm deliberately avoiding
playing this bishop p5 and i really want
to just go for long castle again i'm
gonna avoid doing this bishop b5
and you know you're having a little bit
of a trouble now you're not i mean i'm
not so sure how to
play if i'm not playing bishop b5 and
keep advantage
so that's kind of why you want to be
careful with
how you choose where to castle because
you see opponent is delaying their
castle so it's kind of important for us
to keep our options open as well
now
i kind of like this bishop b5 primarily
because keeping options open i'm not
opposed to taking it but if i do take it
now my lawn castle is going to have some
um issues now so
probably i'm not gonna be doing that
anymore there we go
and another's opponent that's totally
fine
and this is a very comfortable position
this pawn on g5 is funny
uh this position is just
comfortable for us opponent is the one
who's struggling with gaining more
center gaining more
things to attack from us and we're the
one who has
more say on the pawn structure more stay
in the center a little bit more center
development and we have potential
weaknesses that we can start to consider
how to attack so i'm oh actually i'm
happy with this
so yeah
all right
this is actually surprisingly the most
sane g6 line i saw today
so
yeah so if you're the one who who likes
to play this um g6 d6 ideas try to delay
your castle and just confuse the
opponent because if you cast it too
early on then sure i'm gonna castle two
and then we go into attack but if you
actually keep your cast a little bit
longer it's it doesn't mean you're not
gonna do it it just means that you're
gonna wait to see what opponent does
small tip hopefully none of my future
opponents are watching this
um
like in scotch also it kind of bugs me
when opponent is not casting immediately
and most people do
but when they're not casting then like
they keep their options open and now i
have to keep my options open and i can't
start to cast you know i have to kind of
start to
make this too many decisions for if they
cast out this way if they canceled that
way and no we're not playing together
right now don't don't take notes
yeah
so
yeah just keep that in mind confuse
opponent
all right now let's finally get to my
game yay
now let's say bishop e7 now what do you
do
oh yeah i forgot to mention this so
non-test related but funny thing
in persian calendar
uh first day of spring is the first of
new year so it's no ruse it's not just
in persian it's like multiple countries
but around the same region so it's kind
of funny it makes total sense too first
day of spring start the first new year
now
now the first day of spring is the
middle of march nobody cares
anyway so that's called nauru so for
those of you who celebrated happy naurus
thank you thank you
all right i'm getting bunch of f4s and
bishop of fours and
ah thank you patrick yeah
all right
not the biggest fan of pawn four but i
am quite fond of bishop before and so is
negi
in this game i went bishop e2 first
because again i wanted to kind of
confuse the opponent just a little bit
and then i won bishop f4
and um
now
which side do you think we should castle
and again this wasn't a this is an
important game because every game is
important but it wasn't like a killer
peak heal type of game because you know
if you're playing a tournament last
round you need a norm you need a medal
or whatever it's going to be kill or be
killed type of style this wasn't that
this was just someone who was
a bit higher rated
that i've already beaten once
but
so i definitely wanted revenge
surprisingly this is a weird opening
transfer revenge
but then again if he played like e5 i
would have probably gone down fortnite
and it's already a draw so
probably sicilian would have been the
best choice for him eh well not my
problem
okay i'm seeing a lot of kingside
castles now whoa
why
i mean it's possible but
come on people what happened to sense of
adventure
the only
the the big difference between like now
that they haven't played g6 is your
queen you don't need to do queen d2 you
can instead go queen d3 and maybe you
know try to switch the queen that way
i've done a few games like this in
sicilians
when i did like queen d3 ideas
so feel free to check out the sicilian
neverending series that we did for like
oh my god how many weeks that was 12
weeks eight weeks it was months all i
know is it was months and tracy was
about to pull out her hair and
we finally wrapped it up
just to start a new one
yeah
so
let's say opponent plays
okay so many options here
uh
let's go with knight a6 first because
knight ah let's go to d5 first
the music stopped
[Music]
why here why not
it's the golden question isn't it
ah long castle is appealing yeah thank
you yeah lawn cast is pretty cool
i might there say dope because if they
take you don't have to take it you can
just go queen g3 now you have funny
ideas here you have funny ideas there
you have funny ideas everywhere and
opponents kind of stuck
because let's say they try to you know
run away
actually can they run away
not here not they're not they're not
there let's go they go there
yay
they can't really run away can't let's
say just they try to develop
again
they saved the night but
you know what no no this is better yeah
just bring the pressure because if you
play bishop c7 they have to play queen
e8 you still have advantage but why
should i help them make a choice right
i'm going to play nine to five and
torture you now you have to make a
choice
now
so yeah that's kind of the thing about
d5 if they take we can just take and
it's still pretty pretty nice
you have great center you have great
development your pieces are centralized
it's just
great all around so that was the thing
about d5 let's talk about knight a6
looks a little weird i actually haven't
had anybody play this with me
but what do you think
should he use king stuff or queen stuff
uh as a principal a3
might help opponents so i'm kind of
meh about it
if you want to go long castle that's
okay but the opponent wants to play
knight c5 so
i kind of like queen g2 yeah you see
this special e2 made a lot of sense
because stops bunch of this knight h5s
right
so that's one other way to consider it
now if opponent goes knight c5 great
we don't have to we could also do like
bishop f3 but i'm completely happy with
this
and you can start poking around
if they go like f5 f5s are always a
little weird for me to be honest
whenever opponent does it even on scotch
we can take and this is a very
comfortable position yeah black is doing
a bit better than most of the other
lines we saw so far but
as white i don't really have any
concerns because they still have to take
a lot of time to try and attack my king
and the only
good thing they got going is that they
have this centralized pawn that i can't
take away from them
but also i could try and push my h-pawn
so it's i think this is more of a fair
fight than any other line we've seen so
far
that's why 96 is kind of the best one
for black
uh if you go like king h8 has black well
that's totally cool like i now have to
move the bishop and if you take well
amazing that just well that's going to
be fun so you're not going to take as
black let's say knight f6
now you can simply continue with like
um
well not this guy's under attack so
not just long castle either f3 or bishop
f3 and you know this is again very
comfortable position
since you have your queen on g3
you're
not going to be doing those like f3 g4
ideas anymore so this is a little a
little bit of a difference dynamic but
um
you're still attacking it's just you're
not primarily attacking with pawns per
se you're now kind of switching the gear
between attacking with pawns a little
attacking with pieces a little so it's
more of a mix than just pawn attacks
all right
now
if bishop f6 again since you your bishop
did its job you can try to come back and
just exchange it off and that's totally
cool because we want them to take it
now again this is happy happy times yay
again now this is again
great you get the edge file it doesn't
necessarily grant you a win obviously
but it gives you a bit of an edge
for this game
and
i like this
more attacks more eatings
it's just very comfortable again you
have to convert it to a full advantage
and a full win but white is very very
comfortable should you shouldn't really
have any real troubles here so yeah you
can
oh yeah i was just showing as like a
potential idea it doesn't have to be
this because like you have the edge file
but you still need to be able to create
an attack but you can't just start
doubling up because opponents could just
try and run away so
what about i'm sorry
you can but what if i just play like i'm
gonna say g6 or
yeah let's say like g6
yeah
let's say i try to attack over here
for example
again you're better
but
your rook is great where it is on the h
file so you that's kind of why we're
trying to attack the other weakness that
they have
okay i was
thinking about doubling but
i mean i didn't see it through but i was
wanting to double
even if you try to like
go a little bit of a more
longer route a
you double but you can't really get
through
so that's a bit of a problem all right
now finally
we get to my game
but the time is up so it's okay we're
gonna try and push it through
uh it wasn't it was just a really nice
game but we already got through the most
of the big ideas
so
okay
exactly oh there we go
i can't take that away from audience
still they'll come after me
all right
but
now i'm very comfortable with this
position
i'm already you know we're adding the
opposite side castles you're already
kind of determining where i should
place my i think b4 is a little too
early honestly
maybe
because i feel like if this pawn was
already on a4 and then you played b4
then i would have to push this knight
backwards but that's also two moves that
you have to do so
b4 should be okay
i'm i'm comfortable with this
and to be fair uh
idea was okay but it wasn't the best one
i probably should have started with like
king b1
the idea is if you go c5 then i can
simply move this light away attack
these guys and even if it get exchanged
because the king is defending the pawn i
have the option to consider re-routing
the knight whereas when your king is
still here your pawn is defenseless and
this knight is kind of in a awkward pin
situation
so i went to h4 not a horrible idea but
and
i can still try and
set up shop for
h5h6 but i think i kind of confused
myself in the game because i really
wanted to
mix it up but i couldn't and then this
one was weak so i had to do
and e5 is not what i wanted to go for
because i don't want to make opponents
pieces strong
bishop f3 might have been the best one
but i chose kind of i went for f3
instead and here is when i actually
started to
see the problems with my position
because c5 you move the knight
and now they get c4
and now black has pretty nice advantage
but it's not over because black still
needs to develop blackstone needs to be
able to break through and can have this
attack so it's not that easy for them
uh knight c6 is a very logical move
which they didn't do they went knight d7
i'm assuming 97 is because
to follow it up with some ideas and
exchange this knight
and
my position is worse because i messed up
the center and
that's so funny because in like span of
two three moves and i didn't really
blunder
but
because i let my opponent
relax and you know expand their um
their pieces and their center now i'm in
trouble so i started to try and attack
anyways
and
now
taking is a very
risky i would not do that
because well you are very i'm very close
to getting checkmated so
just i don't want to get checkmated this
bishop is a real monster
i wouldn't do this
under no circumstances i want that
bishop to be that's free so i tried to
still salvage the position keep it up
and i'm surprising i won this game so
technically i was trying to do perpetual
but anyways
um
i'm still trying to attack right i'm
just gonna run through some of the ideas
that i had which is for example maybe i
can do this but then upon gets c3 so
all right
here i think was a very crucial moment
for black what do you think is the best
move for black because he went bishop c5
and it gave me some chances to free up
my queen
right
so what do you think was the best move
for black here
no my oh was was it b3 move um well i
guess first they got to make a choice
about what to do with this bishop
i mean b3 is
problematic because they can't take back
that's that's one of the reasons i have
that queen on d4 because i want to try
and protect my king as much as possible
and that's another thing that proves
that this position is not that easy to
win for black too they have to really
um try and well torture me
give me a little more room to breathe
and well
so what what should black do something
with that bishop
but what
uh b3 is still too early
for black
because even if they play b3 now i take
and they go right rook b8 well that's
totally fine
because you can't really you still have
the same problems and now i have
defenders too for my king as well
so f6 what should black do okay bishop
fate is one of them the other one is
just take it
and if i take back now take knight takes
e2 because now you're attacking queen
you want to go knight c3 and even if i
take take you know the other position
that what happened in the game my queen
was on d5 so that guy fell but now
that's not it anymore this is just well
i'm pretty lost now
did knight f5 also
before
here
yeah
um honestly possible but
i feel like the the thing with b3 is
it's
it helps open my position as well so i i
still have some defenses
so you you sh like
um the squares are very weak so if you
can get a knight here if you can have a
bishop in this diagonal up toast
but if you're going to try and push
pawns it helps my position because it
opens up some of my pieces to come
defend my king too
so it's just a matter of how to torture
me better
i've also been watching the tv show good
place so
it's quite fun
the good place
oh yeah it's pretty good so i'm coming
up with some new analogies
anyways
yeah b3 looks really good but white
keeps defending it so it's not time
bishop f6 would have been best and then
i take and then you take and i probably
would have resigned here because well
there's not much to do but after bishop
c5
opponents kind of blew up their
advantage now
they they you know it was like
minus five now it's minus a little bit
it's like minus half so
pretty good
what do we do it's kind of funny um i
was happy trying to repeat this like
some repetition ideas but i couldn't
really come up with it first of all they
want to checkmate me so i gotta stop
that
and
uh probably taking would be best for her
opponent but he just went through k8
i centralize my queen
they pretty they close up this diagonal
which i'm happy about and i also have
new ways of defending
and i might be able to do new stuff
okay probably in hindsight you should
come back to not let my background get
all funky because now they could do this
again
i recall we were in real time trouble
but
okay they didn't play rookie one not my
problem
but yeah
uh if i was playing more accurately
rookie one background is a problem so
first come back defend it then switch it
to the other side
that's a good title how to torture me
better
that
feels like
anyways
um uh
i mean
ah
come on little joke
i mean even if queen b3
they can just go the other way
would i give a permanent weakness like
that
i want to go back in time like five
years and smack myself wait six years
that hurts
six years ago
my god
well in hindsight my cat was not alive
six years ago
so let's not go back in time
his birthday is coming up
he's not six years old i thought i took
him to the mat like
five years ago
wait
he is born 2017.
so fine
when he was just like one year
yeah yeah his birthday is april 7th i'm
gonna get him a lot of catnip let him
get high and
give him some tuna as well i have to see
if i can mix it up somehow
all right
yeah
now but this position was like somehow
fine and i st and my opponent managed to
royally
see now i realize that oh okay let's go
back see
but
no this was fine and to top it off my
opponent started to mess it up yay
still not there
still not there
all right come on let me get to the good
place
oh there we go now it's the messing up
part
now
what opponents should have tried to done
to me with this rookie one background
problem i did the dim
yeah this background problem is pretty
nice
and even if opponent is trying to defend
it this is a permanent weakness so their
queen has to permanently stay
defending it which gives me more of an
edge to try and bring more attackers
bring more problems so i like that
hi i enjoyed this rookie seven
nice i tried to repeat for a second but
i didn't have to
i could have just went for like maybe
rookie five but now because of how much
i have peace activity
my opponent is in deep trouble the
material is the same as it was before
the king's miking safety is still
everything is still as it was my bishop
is still useless weird thing but i have
peace activity with the few pieces that
i have so peace activity is very very
very important in chess
and now i got just 27 and voila well i
guess technically this would have been
faster i guess
well anyways let's just pretend i didn't
miss that queen e7 is also pretty
beautiful
i mean if you take it's still checkmate
right there we go it's all that matters
checkmating two or three is the same
but yeah it's really really important so
when i'm talking about center
centralizing pieces good development
purposeful development all of those
things i'm not just shooting
cool chest terminology at you um i
actually mean it it's really important
to have your king to be safe however
safe it can be right now surprisingly my
king was
safe because opponents couldn't attack
it
but once created a nice blanket around
my king
my pieces were more active than
opponents because the opponent messed up
and gave me that option to activate my
pieces which i earlier also messed up
and gave them center so
overall this is quite a fun game
but
the main thing to take away from it was
the ideas that we did with like if g6
you have that f3 g4 idea if not g6 you
have that queen d3 queen
g3 idea and the how to attack and
opposite side castles and
the all the center development king
safety peace activity all those fun
things that i always talk about
i feel like i need to get tattoos of
them on my eyelids but all right
so
i'm glad it's this was fun so this is
the main thing for philidor that we
talked about next week i'm going to try
and wrap up the filter just some little
ideas that is in negi's book but i
don't have a game from myself that i'm
going to show
and then we're going to dive into french
and karaoke and
yeah his book is pretty good get it
all right uh we're gonna switch to
twitch analyzer games for a little bit
and then i'm gonna go home and sleep
so
uh i'll see you on twitch in a little
bit
bye
[Music]
you